Symbols are nothing without the
women and men that give them meaning
that show represents a lot of people
so we're partners co-workers
not necessarily a team no
we look damn good though
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
falcon and winter soldier episode 6 finale
trailer video also talk about post credit scene
theories obviously because they have to wrap up so
many story lines so if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes i'll
be doing loki episode videos after this too that's
going to be the next big marvel disney plus series
happening but careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on falcon and winter soldier so
far if you have not been watching the episodes
obviously starting with that post-credits scene
there john walker making himself a new captain
america shield i'm sure that will totally end well
for him still wearing the captain america costume
that he was given when the government named him
steve rogers successor except the whole thing here
is he's giving off this really dark twisted iron
man one energy with this scene the way they play
the hammer strikes before the scene starts like it
starts in black with the hammer strikes then they
show the montage of him banging on the shield the
exact same way that iron man forged the iron
man mark 1 armor john walker made that shield
in a cave with a box of scraps everyone posts all
the memes and the funny thing about that iron man
moment it's so iconic marvel has used it in so
many of their trailers the last several years
they actually ended avengers end game the credits
with the sound of the i think five hammer strikes
it was the closest thing that we got to an
avengers endgame post credit scene although
technically there were some post credit scenes
that were supposed to happen that they wound up
just sort of cutting out because they turned them
into disney plus series like there was going to
be a Wandavision post-credit scene setting up the
events of Wandavision episode one but paul bettany
said that kevin feige called him and said we gotta
cut the scene because we're just going to save
that for when we get to the wandevision episodes
but they did actually film footage in avengers
end game that was going to be for a post credit
scene for his character for vision and wanda
but the whole thing with the hammer strikes is
if you actually listen if you re-watch avengers
end game after the actual credits you just
hear five hammer strikes and it's meant to be
the book and like you begin with iron man 1 he
influences so much of the tone of all the movies
that came during the infinity saga so it only
made sense that they would end the infinity saga
with an iron man moment the most iconic iron man
moment next to him snapping the infinity gauntlet
only the whole thing with john walker here
is that he's on the fast train to crazy town
like obviously he doesn't think that he's crazy
he thinks that he's the only sane person here like
yelling at this big panel who's trying to take the
title of captain america away from him basically
giving him everything but a dishonorable discharge
they took away all of his benefits his rank pretty
much everything told him that he basically had to
take a giant l for the rest of his life so the way
they're telling his story they want his character
to feel like the government the military that
spent his whole life up to this point training him
to be this weapon telling him that he was special
that he was the next great hope for the country
to feeling like they discarded him like a piece of
trash which is a common theme of veteran stories
so they obviously want you to sympathize with him
a little bit like the government just kind of
throwing him away when they're done with him
like in real life you hear about veterans
suffering from ptsd other kinds of disorders that
they get after they're discharged and a lot of
them wind up becoming homeless addicted to drugs
tom holland mr spider-man himself even just did
a movie with the russo brothers the people who
got done directing avengers infinity war avengers
end game the captain america movies which a lot
of the series draws from it was called cherry it
was all about the terrible things that happened to
this u.s soldier when the military discharges
him but fails to help him get the proper care
that he needs so john walker right now is
kind of feeling that energy in the contessa
julie louis dreyfus character comes to offer him
salvation so to speak even though it sounds really
sinister the way she's talking about it they want
you to feel very weird about her character like
she is definitely not a good person even though
she pretends to be she was kind of like that on
veep like a very slippery character she kind of
seemed like a dirt bag even though she was kind
of a good character at the same time just this
really weird anti-hero type of character that show
was more of a dark comedy and obviously falcon
and winter soldier is more of a drama but i did
feel like her cameo scene here was a little funny
in a dark way the way she was talking circles all
around john walker like he was just confused the
whole time what's happening here this business
card there's nothing on it what's going on but
she slips in and tells him everything he wants
to hear because clearly she's manipulating him you
taking the super soldier serum was the best thing
that ever happened to you it's made you very
attractive to quote unquote some people people
basically looking for mercenaries to hire people
with nothing left to lose that's basically what
her character is all about in the comics though
manipulating people the same way that baron zemo
is a master at manipulating people she is 100% bad
news obviously but he's eating this all up because
the sting of feeling betrayed by his government is
so fresh so he is on his way to going full karen
on falcon winter soldier in the flag smashers
in the finale like the karen version of captain
america the same way scarlet witch went full karen
during wandavision for a little while they never
really addressed that during wanda vision like
she just kind of flies off at the end of the
series like oh wait a minute didn't you manipulate
and trap all these people here for a whole week we
didn't really address that so i think the question
with john walker's character isn't so much
what he's going to do next we all expect him to go
off the rails it's more about how they're going to
set him up to be more of the us agent character
from the comics and potentially joined the first
version of the mcu thunderbolts team i know there
are all kinds of theories about how they're going
to end the series with his character but i don't
think you kill off a character like that like he's
got super soldier serum he's got skills clearly
and he's just really complicated which i think
just makes for really good drama and situations
in potential thunderbolt series the whole thing
with that though is that in order to be a member
of the thunderbolts you kind of have to start out
being a criminal in prison that's the whole deal
it's like marvel's version of the suicide squad
so that would mean that he'd have to be arrested
at the end of falcon and winter soldier in the
finale at some point they could potentially
arrest him for violating the government's order
to stand down and no longer act in any capacity
against the flag smashers which clearly he doesn't
listen to because we see him fighting them in
the finale trailer but then on the other side
of this obviously you have all the falcon and
winter soldier stuff they're going to have to
stop the flag smashers from killing anyone because
they're obviously going off the rails too without
escalating things even more that's the whole
thing that was john walker's problem is that yes
they did need to stop the flag smashers but in
a way that wouldn't help the flag smashers rally
more support for their cause which is basically
what happened when he killed that flag smasher
in public like everyone saw it and the way it was
spun made him seem like the villain made the flag
smashers seem more like martyrs rallying more
support for their cause escalating things even
further so it sounds like what happens is at some
point the contessa like she says pick up the phone
when i call you and she's going to call him and
set him on the flag smashers like go to new york
city and get rid of these people the slimy way her
character sounds she wouldn't tell him to go kill
a bunch of people she'd just say deal with the
problem and that would basically be her way of
telling him kill all them we don't care just get
rid of them remember one of her comic book names
is madame hydra and you don't name someone
madame hydra if they're a good character
also just talking about some of the fight scenes
the really cool thing about falcon's new vibranium
captain america suit the wingsuit that he's
looking at here at the end of episode 5 is you
remember how john walker ripped his old wings out
destroying his suit basically well now falcon has
a vibranium wing suit in addition to the original
captain america shield which is vibranium itself
john walker only has the regular metal shield
no vibranium weapons no vibranium armor so
think about it this way they get into a fight with
each other falcon can basically slice his shield
in half like butter with his wings it'd be like
thanos slicing captain america's shield with his
giant axe weapon into boot the entire wingsuit is
way stronger just in general so walker wouldn't be
able to rip the vibranium wings out this time what
i'm hoping for is that when falcon puts on the new
suit and heads into battle he doesn't totally
understand how all the new functions work and
because it's wakandan vibranium tech it's way more
advanced with way more abilities than his old wing
suit and he just winds up learning on the fly like
activating the new wings and it just becomes a
really badass cooler version of him flying around
in the wingsuit we've seen him use the wingsuit in
fights before like the batroc scene during episode
1. just imagine a much bigger badder version of
that happening with the vibranium version of
the suit also you have to remember that batrack
is going to be going after him in the finale
too so it's like he's got to fight john walker
and he's got to fight batroc at the same time
as well that vibranium is going to come in handy
the finale is supposed to be over 60 minutes
long so obviously there are a whole bunch of
story lines to wrap up hopefully they answer all
the bigger questions they got into a bit of a
problem during the Wandavision finale because of
the virus shutdown they had to cut a whole bunch
of scenes that resolved some of the story lines so
that's why the actual version of the finale that
we wound up watching for Wandavision it just felt
like there was a lot of stuff that was missing
like wait a minute you didn't answer all these
questions that you picked up on during the series
hopefully because they had a little extra time to
finish the falcon and winter soldier episodes they
don't have the same problem the whole thing with
a contessa character julie louis-dreyfus character
i'm not expecting a ton with her in the finale but
she might wind up being the person at the end of
the show or in a post-credits scene who contacts
john walker and zemo about the thunderbolts like
instead of thunderbolt ross who a lot of us have
been expecting to put the thunderbolts together
in the mcu her character could be the one to
start putting the team together and because
her character in the comics had this long running
association with nick fury and shield before she
revealed she was a russian sleeper agent she
could be working with thunderbolt ross on the dl
like her showing up in broad daylight at this big
government hearing for john walker implies that
she has ties to the us government i still think
the evidence is stronger that she winds up being
the power broker versus sharon carter i think the
whole thing with the sharon carter storyline emily
vancamp has been saying in her interviews that
all sharon really wants is to get the pardon
from the us government so that she can go home
so everything she's been doing in madrapore using
batroc the leaper the flagsmashers has something
to do with that my only complaint with her
storyline is that they're kind of giving us the
cliff's notes version they're only six episodes
it'd be nice if we had 10 episodes so we had
more time to spend with her character explaining
exactly what she's been doing this whole time but
right now they're just implying that she's been
playing both sides of this chessboard in order to
get that pardon manipulate events to her benefit
and if julia louis dreyfus character really does
wind up being the power broker sharon carter could
have some association with her just trying to out
maneuver her i would love for thunderbolt ross to
secretly be the power broker because the storyline
is all about the super soldier serum the weapons
plus program but right now there's just been no
overt clues or hints that he's going to show up
on the series and we've just got this massive
cameo scene with a huge actor julia dreyfuss
playing a comic book villain from the comics who
pretends to be a good person working inside shield
in the government so it just feels like they're
setting her character up for an even bigger
reveal like they wouldn't just bring her on for
five seconds and then you never see her again
obviously something bigger is going to happen with
her character so early theory i think that they
bring her character back in future marvel disney
plus series and marvel movies like hopefully for
the thunderbolt series when they get around to
making that but everyone post all your predictions
for the finale in the comments below i'll be
doing a couple more bonus videos for falcon and
winter soldier in the next couple of days so just
leave all your requests or your big questions in
the comments there was also some really cool
spider-man 3 no way home doctor octopus news
so i'll do a video for that soon too everyone
click here for my full falcon winter soldier
episode 5 video and click here for that brand
new thor 4 love and thunder first look teaser
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!